Let me take this question.
What's your background? What's your
question?
>> Hi. Um, Terren, my background is I live
in West Africa, Ghana. I don't
>> denomination.
>> Yes. I have actually three questions if
you don't mind.
>> What's your Christian denomination?
>> I'm Protestant.
>> What's your question?
>> I'm assuming, but I'm kind of in a place
where I'm trying to figure things out if
that makes sense. It's
>> okay, brother. Okay. So, what's your
question?
So the first one is on the idea of like
a true church. I hear a lot of the times
where it's like Catholics are saying
they're the one true church, Orthodox is
saying they're the one true church, etc.
But it's like, isn't the true church
just believers of Christ? Cuz
>> really,
>> I mean, we
>> are the believers of Christ.
Like anybody who has accepted Jesus as
their Lord and personal savior.
>> Jehovah's Witnesses and Mormons, they
are also the true church because they
accept Jesus as their Lord and Savior.
>> I mean, no.
>> Oh, so now you have to qualify it. So
you change your answer. So what's a true
believer?
>> A true believer is somebody who's okay.
Probably one accepted Jesus as Lord and
personal savior and two
Jehovah Witnesses.
>> What?
>> Jehovah's Witnesses believe Jesus is the
Lord and Savior. So they're the true
church.
>> No, you also have to probably like
accept the trinity. Like there's certain
core principles qualifications.
So it's Oh, so you're changing answer.
Oh, so you believe in the trinity. Okay.
So now you're saying you got to believe
in the trinity. And so that's it.
Like there are core fundamentals that
you probably need to have.
>> The core fundamentals are who told you
what they are.
>> I'm ass like I'm just assuming I don't.
>> You see the point? You've already
assumed to know what Christianity is and
you already assumed that you have the
criteria to determine what a true
believer is, but it's all based on your
understanding. So now you're making
yourself your own pope. How do you know
you're right?
Yeah. I don't
>> exactly. That's what I'm trying to
That's why I'm asking you so you can
realize because then if you tell me,
well, the Bible says so. I say, well,
first of all, it's your interpretation
of the Bible that says so. That's number
one. But number two, even the Bible you
have was given to you through the
church. Because how do you know what the
Bible is apart from that church?
>> Yeah.
>> So that means now you got to look in
history, right?
>> Yeah.
Look at history to see the church for
the first 300 years that God used to
preserve the Bible, copy the manuscripts
accurately and explain them. Those were
the Christians that taught the very
things that you'll find in the Catholic
Orthodox communions. For example, I've
done this all the time. I'll do it
again.
You ask the oriental Orthodox, Eastern
Orthodox, Syrian church, Catholic Church
about what they believe in common, not
the differences. Because the difference
is they're there, but they're minor. If
you actually know what the differences
are, they're not even based on core
doctrines. It's the understanding of how
Christ is one person with two natures.
That's what really caused the division.
But you ask them here, they're in my
chat. Fl A or O oriental Orthodox,
Eastern Orthodox, Catholics, Syrian
church. Do you all believe in Mary's
perpetual virginity? Yep. H Do you all
believe Mary was kept pure by the grace
of God so she wouldn't stain herself so
that her body would be pure to be the
ark of the covenant? Yep. Do you believe
Mary was assumed into heaven? They all
celebrate the dorm mission. The dorm
mission is that the Lord took her soul
and body into heaven. That's what they
all celebrate. Yep. That's the
assumption.
Do you all believe intercession of
saints? Saints are alive, perfected,
praying for us. Yep. Do you all believe
in honoring them because of their status
before God and God glorifying them? Yep.
Do you all believe the Eucharist becomes
the body and blood of Christ? Yes. You
believe water baptism is used by the
spirit to save you? Yes. Do you believe
in infant baptism? Yes. On and on it
goes. So then the question is these
churches are in schism. Meaning if you
go from the 400s these churches broke
off. Syrian church condemned as
historians or interthodox rejected the
language of calcedon.
And yet these churches separated in
schism,
without internet, without email, without
iPhones. They have all these beliefs in
common and these are dogmatic teachings
that are non-negotiable. How do you
explain that they all believed these
things in common when they were in
schism since the 400s and they didn't
have internet or iPhone to communicate
with one another? nor would they cuz
they condemned each other as heretics.
So where did these beliefs come from
that they all hold in common?
>> Where did it come from?
>> I mean they were passed down right
>> from whom?
>> Okay. There's the argument that they
were passed down directly from the
disciples over time. And it's like
>> Yeah. Because if you have churches that
are separated by thousands of miles and
you have even the church at Rome that
you need a to get on a ship to get to,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Thousands of miles and they all have
this in common. That means these
teachings were spread universally long
before the fifth century 400s. Hence
they believe this in common. That means
these teachings
must be very old, must be very ancient
for them to be found everywhere you go.
So how do you explain that? If God is in
charge of the church, then he's not
going to allow the church to accept
false teachings universally because then
the church is corrupt. It's lost. And
then how did Christ preserve his church?
Because without the truth, you can't be
saved because these are not corrupt
teachings. And even though they're in
schism, the very fact that they were one
and hold these doctrines in common shows
that though they're in schism, they're
not in schism to Christ, they're still
part of Christ and they're one in
Christ.
That's why these different churches
preserve the same core truths. That's
Christ's way of showing that even
churches in schism who don't agree and
may condemn the other church as having
fallen from grace. The fact that they
all have these teachings is a guarantee
these teachings must be from Christ
because you cannot say that one emperor
or one individual forced these beliefs
on all of them because that never
happened.
>> Yeah.
>> So then that by by Protestantism. Even
your Protestantism comes out of the
Roman Catholic Church.
You as a Protestant, you come out of the
Catholic Church. That's your history. Go
read your history. The reformers were
all the children of the Roman Catholic
Church. Luther himself was a Catholic
priest. So that you yourself
are the offspring of the Roman Catholic
Church whether you accept it or not.
Yeah. Yeah, I do understand that, right?
But then it's like I probably been
raised in a system, I don't know if you
know how the culture is here, where it's
like
>> the what
>> the culture um here specifically in this
part of the world where let's say 90% of
believers are
born into Protestantism, right? As
opposed to like Catholics or Orthodox,
right? And it's what's natural or common
for us.
>> Yeah.
>> And so even the I
>> let me just don't worry about the 90%.
Let God worry about them. Worry about
you because God is exposing you to more
truth.
>> God meets people where they're at. The
new narrow gate with anttocross. We've
already covered all these topics in my
series.
Let me re explain the difference. God
meets people where they're at. These
Protestants to no fault of their own.
They don't know any better. God extends
mercy, love, and grace to them and saves
them because he meets them where they're
at. Don't worry about them. Worry about
you. Because God in his grace is giving
you more revelation and illumination.
You know more, you'll be held
accountable.
So instead of focusing on the 90% who
may not know what you know, what are you
going to do with what you know? Because
the more you know, the greater your
judgment.
>> Yeah.
Don't worry about the 90%. That's God's
business, not yours.
>> Okay? But then there's one difficulty
where it's like then where do I
fellowship for example?
Cuz I think there's only one Orthodox
church that I know around
>> and it's like it's quite far. I won't be
able to every
>> brother your God will make a way if he
sees your heart is sincere. You would go
travel far if you could for a better
education, for a better life, or a
better paying job.
Jesus is worthy. We make that sacrifice.
And God sees your condition. If you
can't get there, he's not going to damn
you to hell because you can't get there.
If he sees your heart and you want say,
"God, now I'm convinced. These are the
only churches for me. Can you make a way
for me to get there?" God sees your
heart. He's not going to damn you to
hell. That because you could go, you're
not going. You want to go, but you're
not able. God will meet you where you're
at.
And if all you have now, because to no
fault of your own, you can't get to
anywhere else, keep going to the
Protestant church. But since you now
know that their sacraments are not
proper in that when they give you a
cracker and grape juice, that's not the
Eucharist. You don't partake of it.
>> You don't partake of it. Like here, if I
were to go to an evangelical church,
because there's evangelical church
nearby, where if I go on a Monday night
just to hear a sermon, they have open
communion, which is not communion, which
is cracker and grape juice. I don't dare
touch it because I'd be sinning because
I know better.
>> Okay?
>> So, you don't can do that's all you can
do. But
>> you go there until God makes the way,
but don't partake of their sacraments.
That's it. So that's the only option you
have in light of your situation.
And God understands better than you do
your situation. He understands better
than you do your situation. I say, "Ah,
sucks being you going to No, he's not
that kind of God."
>> Yeah.